mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
asha and lata are two sisters
asha's age right now is the two digit
number a b
and latta's age right now is the two
digit number cd
if you write lata's age after asha's age
you get the four digit number abcd
and it happens to be a perfect square
number
an interesting thing happens if you
repeat the exercise in 11 years if again
you write lotta's age after asha's age
you get a four digit number that also
happens to be a perfect square
the question is how old are asha and
latta currently
in other words solve for the two-digit
number a b and the two-digit number c d
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall the difference of squares formula
x squared minus y squared is equal to
the quantity x plus y multiplied by the
quantity x minus y
this is a fun equation to illustrate
geometrically
suppose we have a square with an area
equal to x squared and another square
with an area equal to y squared
if we subtract the smaller squares area
from the larger squares area we get the
area x squared minus y squared but we
can also calculate the area in another
way
this shape will be the composition of
two different rectangles
one rectangle will have one side length
equal to y and another side length equal
to x minus y the other rectangle will
have one side length equal to x and the
other side length equal to x minus y
we can join the two sides that have
length equal to x minus y
we will then get a larger rectangle
where one side is equal to x minus y and
the other side is equal to x plus y
thus the same area can be represented by
the area of this rectangle which is
equal to the quantity x plus y
multiplied by the quantity x minus y
we will use this equation to solve the
problem
now we have the ages a b and c d and we
know that a b c d is equal to a perfect
square so we'll write it as equal to y
squared for some integer y
in 11 years asha's age will be a b plus
11 and latta's age will be cd plus 11.
in other words we need to add 11 to each
of the digits a b c and d
so we can add 11 11 to a b c d the four
digit number
and then we will get another perfect
square
so we have a b c d plus 11 11 is equal
to another perfect square which we'll
write as x squared for another integer x
now consider these two equations
we will subtract the y squared equation
from the x squared equation
when we do that we will cancel out the
four digit number a b c d and we get 11
11 is equal to x squared minus y squared
from here we can use the difference of
squares formula we'll factor the right
hand side
it'll be equal to the quantity x plus y
multiplied by the quantity x minus y
we can then factor 11 11 and that's
equal to 11 multiplied by 101.
now recall that x squared and y squared
are four digit numbers
this means x and y have to be integers
between 32 and 99 any lower you won't
get a four digit number and any higher
you won't get a four digit number either
this means x plus y cannot be equal to
11 11.
this is because x and y have a maximum
value of 99
so x plus y and x minus y are integer
factors of 11 11.
11 times 101 is the prime factorization
therefore x plus y must be the proper
factor 101 and x minus y will be the
factor of 11.
we can then add these two equations
together to cancel out the y terms
we then get 112 is equal to 2x which
means 56 is equal to x
we can then look at this equation and
see that x minus y is equal to 11 which
means y is equal to 45.
we will then recall that y squared is
equal to abcd
we thus need to square 45 and that's
equal to 2025
and thus we can solve that a b is equal
to 20 and cd is equal to 25
asha's age is 20 and lotta's age is 25
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you